ayer atrás tras conocerse las a las
contundentes pruebas los vídeos y los
testimonios que entregaron los
demócratas que mostraban como donald
trump sabía de estos ataques antes de
que ocurrieran como incitó esta
violencia el 6 de enero y como no hizo
nada al respecto el senador richard
blumenthal se preguntaba que si el voto
fuese secreto los republicanos en
realidad si terminarían absorbiendo a
donald trump
y es que tras presentar estos vídeos
muchos republicanos que estaban en
plenaria se mostraron afectados
afectados de ver como efectivamente las
palabras de donald trump terminaron
incitando a la violencia pero lo que
están diciendo muchos analistas es que a
pesar de haberse visto afectados los
republicanos lo votarán en contra de
trump primero porque no se van a
arriesgar a perder el apoyo los votos de
sus simpatizantes en los estados que
representan y por ende pues arriesgar la
reelección en el senado y segundo porque
si votan en contra de donald trump le
dejaría en el camino libre de largo
todo para que el oro champ pues cree
este tercer político el partido patriota
que dice que podría crear en caso de
tener en la falta de apoyo por parte del
de los republicanos